talking about safety on Fremont Street
just this week police say a hit and run
involving a drunk driver left two dead
and then two people were hurt in a
shooting near the Third Street stage
some say security is now top of Mind
especially as we count down to New
Year's Eve Sasha Loftus spoke with some
visitors tonight who say they do have
concerns
is the violence
crazy
con Vegas
many say they're more on edge after two
serious situations happen back to back
on Fremont Street on Wednesday police
say a couple was killed in a hit-and-run
crash involving a drunk driver just a
day later two people were hurt in a
shooting near the Third Street stage
people coming out of the pandemic their
minds are not the same and with New
Year's Eve just hours away security is
top of mind for those planning to
celebrate 2023 there now they know
something can like like that can happen
so they're gonna do some like
preventative measures like this on
Friday metal detectors were set up at
the entry to the experience and we're
going to be partnering with the Fremont
Street security and of course Las Vegas
Metro to really just have a presence
Department of Public Safety Chief Jason
Potts says law enforcement will also be
out in full force to make sure
everything runs smoothly I bought about
it it's gonna be safer many relieved to
hear of this effort While others say
it's important to always be aware you
just got to watch your back and be safe
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now